dear fellow scholars this is two minute
papers with károly on IFA here euro
style transfer is an incredible
technique where we have 2 inputs
photographs and the output would be a
combination of these two namely the
content of one and the artistic style of
the other fused together when the first
paper appeared on this topic the news
took the world by storm and lots of
speculative discussions emerged as to
what this could be used for and how it
would change digital art and the video
game industry it is great fun to use
these algorithms and we have also
witnessed a recent proliferation of
phone apps that are able to accomplish
this which is super cool because of two
reasons one the amount of time to go
from a published research paper to
industry-wide application has never been
so small and two the first work required
a powerful computer to accomplish this
and took several minutes of strenuous
computation and now less than 2 years
later it's right in your pocket and can
be done instantly talk about exponential
progress in science and research
absolutely amazing and now while we
feast our eyes upon these beautiful
results let's talk about the selling
points of this expansion of the original
technique the paper contains a nice
formal explanation of the weak points of
the existing file transfer algorithms
the intuition behind the explanation is
that the neural networks think in terms
of neuron activations which may not be
proportional to the color intensities in
the first image styles therefore their
behavior often becomes inconsistent or
different than expected the authors
propose thinking in terms of histograms
which means that the output image should
rely on statistical similarities with
the source images and as we can see the
results look outstanding even when
compared to the original method it is
also important to point out that this
proposed technique is also more
art-directed make sure to have a look at
the paper for more details on that other
ways i've put a link in the video
description this extension is also
capable of texture synthesis which means
that we give it a small image patch that
shows some
sort of repetition and it tries to
continue it indefinitely in a way that
seems completely seamless however we
have to be acutely aware of the fact
that in the computer graphics community
texture synthesis is considered a
subfield of its own with hundreds of
papers and one has to be extremely sure
to have a clear-cut selling point over
the state of the art for the more
interested fellow scholars out there
I've put the survey paper on this in the
video description make sure to have a
look thanks for watching and for your
generous support
let's see you next time
[Music]